so omixologic transcriptomics is an
online training program that is designed
for students that do have the background
in bioinformatics and also don't have
business background bioinformatics so if
you already have a background
bioinformatics perhaps you are familiar
with things like genomic data analysis
maybe processing multiple sequence
alignment or maybe
working with structures and all of these
are very useful tools to start
working with transcriptomic data but
there are specific
things that you need to be prepared to
do if you are trying to analyze
the bulk rna-seq data or the single cell
rnac data that is going to come with an
additional set of challenges and so
that's really what we want to address
today for those of you that have no
background in transcriptomics or in
bioinformatics at all
we want to explain how even though you
don't know
you can still
benefit from understanding the logic
behind some of the analyses and see some
examples that will relate to the biology
that you might understand really well so
really to appreciate how rna-seq is used
for real-world biomedical research
applications including basic and
translational research
so in this program we will see
how relying on analytical methods and
reference databases researchers can
study rna-seq data and understand how
gene expression variation can can
really help us understand biology
that describes that is described by this
rnac data across many conditions and so
to do so effectively bioinformaticians
leverage big data processing methods um
so how can you actually
take gigabytes and maybe in some cases
terabytes of data and
convert them to structure data to tables
of expression then we'll talk about how
exploring
the variability across
this kind of structured data can help us
find major trends and patterns
then we'll talk about statistical
analysis
so what are some of the commonly used
statistical approaches to test
hypotheses and and find variation
between groups of samples or across
many different types of samples so maybe
multiple classes or multiple types of
samples that we have and finally we'll
talk about data mining and machine
learning which will introduce us to
single cell rna-seq and single cell
rna-seq is a growing popular set of
methods they rely on uh kind of a lot of
machine learning that we will introduce
you in the context of bulk rna
sequencing but there are also specific
packages that we will talk about around
rna single cell rna seq
so
why next generation sequence right so
when we speak about next generation
sequencing we're really trying to
understand how proteins that are
expressed
could be measured
using a proxy so using mrna as a proxy
for protein expression why protein
expression well obviously protein
expression is what defines the phenotype
of the cell we can understand a lot of
things by measuring uh for example
surface proteins we can understand the
phenotype what do these cells actually
do how do they interact with cells
around them we can also start looking at
the internal processes by measuring mrna
which we cannot do if we are looking
just at for example immunohistochemistry
and so many different methods have been
designed
to measure
mature mrna including
for example microarrays and microarrays
are a very good way to measure
predefined
levels of mrna but if we are looking at
next generation sequencing we're really
getting a much higher dynamic range
which means that we can start looking
deeper into alternative splicing into
different transcripts into how we can
actually find
exons that might better
give us a sense of separation between
specific groups of samples as you can
see right here so we can really start
looking at all of the biological
activity at the transcription level and
we can try to correlate that with
phenotypes that we know to have both
mechanistic significance but also
clinical significance in terms of
biomarkers for diagnostics and maybe
even for
treatment selection so what we have been
doing
with
our training modules
is we've been trying to design these
kinds of training programs around
multi-omics data sets and that means
that we are really focused on
taking a comprehensive systems biology
look
at how biological processes that happen
within the cell can be interpreted to
apply them to diagnostic and treatment
selection challenges for novel drug
discovery drug repurposing as well as
diagnostics using and leveraging large
data sets so that's what the concept of
omics logic really stands for and in the
context of this program we're going to
kind of take a narrow look at
transcriptomic data which is a very
comprehensive type of data
especially in application to different
types of projects and so what kinds of
things could be used
could rna-seq data be used for
so as i mentioned
cancer biology so to understand
this complex
disease that we call cancer we really
need to understand how
different processes inside cancer cells
develop at the individual level and so
we will present you with a few case
studies to really appreciate the
variability across many different types
of and subtypes of cancer and then we
will also take a look at how we can
classify disease and stratify our
patients how can we actually understand
individual patients in the context of
what we call a diagnostic state a
diagnostic state is a specific diagnosis
that a doctor would
you know assign their patient to and we
will try and see how individual patient
variability fits into that paradigm
we will also take a look at single cell
and tissue composition so we will
actually take a look at how
single cell data can reveal some
important differences between specific
types of tissues and cells for example
immune cells or different types of
treatment
related
specificity of cell states and we will
also look at drug response which is of
course different across many different
cell types
so how will we do this in this program
we will cover six different topics we
will provide you with an overview of
some standard tools and resources for
transcriptomic data analysis we will
take a look at processing next
generation sequencing data using
bioinformatics pipelines for
pre-processing mapping and
quantification we will take a look at
analysis normalization and visualization
of gene and isoform expression we'll
give you an introduction to big data
mining machine learning and predictive
analysis and also introduce you to
analysis of single cell rnac data for
tissue specific expression and finally
introduce you to project examples now
the project examples i think are
critical here because especially when
you study a complex topic like rna-seq
it really comes to life when you have a
very specific challenge that you would
like to address so that's really going
to be the focus for
what we do now one of the tools that's
going to be extremely helpful in this
process is the t-biome for multi-omics
platform
why is this important both for
bioinformaticians and for
non-bioinformaticians
as a bioinformatician you probably are
familiar with the challenges in dealing
with large datasets so again we're
talking about gigabytes and even
terabytes of data
processing those on your computer just
does not make sense so you have to have
access to infrastructure that can
support this kind of analysis and that's
what this platform provides in the
context of this program so you'll be
able to understand some of the
principles using example
pipelines and then you will be able to
try and apply some of these to a data
set of your own for those of you that do
not have a background bioinformatics
this is really a way to understand what
the methods do without having to deal
with some of the technical challenges so
you don't have to know linux you don't
have to know bash scripting you don't
really need to know a lot of the
settings that are
really essential for processing rna-seq
data effectively and i want to show you
how so let's uh put a link here just for
our participants to the platform and i
will give you a brief overview of what
this will look like
so the t by n for platform combines
multiple methods of analysis into
logical workflows these logical
workflows are color coded and linked to
the logic behind the analysis itself so
you will see color coding in this
rna-seq processing pipeline for
pre-processing mapping and
quantification and as a result you'll be
able to compare many different
variations of the same pipeline to
appreciate the different approaches for
pre-processing for mapping on the genome
on the transcriptome or even
alignment-free quantification and
understand some of the differences
between different types of normalization
techniques and different approaches to
actually prepare that table of
expression to ultimately perform
downstream analysis and by downstream
analysis i mean standard type of
analysis like differential gene
expression as well as mapping that on
biological processes as well as
interpreting the meaning of a
differential expression analysis result
in the context of pathways right and so
that's going to be one of the ultimate
goals for this program is for you to be
able to go from the very beginning
where you take the raw data for example
raw data that looks like this with short
reads that are mapped to a particular
portion of the genome
you can then use the mapping of these
short reads to apply to quantification
of whole genes that could be thousands
of nucleotides long
and then using that information to
prepare a structured table of analysis
know how to explore that table of
analysis detect major patterns find
outliers eliminate noise and then go to
a biologically meaningful visualization
that you can start building your
understanding on
to do that we're actually going to look
at many different things like
visualization of basic patterns really
to understand what do these genes look
like how do we compare them across
conditions we will talk about
normalization and transformation how we
can prepare the data to fit some of the
assumptions that we will rely on to
deploy the statistical and analytical
methods that we will use after that for
example log scale transformation and we
will learn how to do that in both excel
r and python and then we will look at
how we can find these meaningful
patterns that we either want to find so
using supervised machine learning or
find new patterns that we yet have not
discovered using data mining
now as you know there are many
challenges along the way and when you
face a real research project what you
want to know is how do these different
methods work together and how can they
reveal important parts parts of your
analysis to you right so how to actually
get the thing that you need from this
type of analysis and an important part
of that is performing exploratory
analysis to find these significant
biological signals
now to do that what we will do is we
will introduce you to the logic behind
this and then also offer you some
asynchronous resources for training so
as i mentioned a lot of this could be
done on the platform
a lot of the downstream exploratory
analysis and visualization you can try
to do it in excel even but the most
practical way is to learn a little bit
of coding at least and even better if
you become somewhat proficient in some
of the coding
approaches so we will give you tutorials
in r and python
for example in r you will be able to
perform the full downstream differential
expression analysis with descriptive
statistics with
volcano plots and mma plots
and then
export tables of differentially
expressed genes and really know how to
run this independently on your own
computer
and obviously in an online environment
that we will introduce you to now what's
important is that i think a lot of
people confuse being
code
you know familiar with some coding
practices
and
really knowing how to do rna-seq data
analysis so one of the things that we
focus on is the logic and and the logic
is kind of code agnostic and so that's
why we'll provide you with similar
tutorials in both r and python how to
perform all of the steps that are needed
to get what you need from the data we
will do this first on the omix logic
portal where you have predefined
assignments for you to complete and
really appreciate what kinds of outputs
you are expecting to get
and then you will be able to download
all of this code and work on this code
independently on your own computer so
that you can get the types of outputs
that you need
and you can really
make sure that you are coming away from
this training with a set of different
codes that are ready for you to do
analysis on a data set of your own now
what kinds of exercises do we provide on
the portal so on the learn portal inside
of the transcriptomics portal the
transcriptomics program
you will find sessions which will be
interactive sessions like what we're
having now
then you will be directed to these
asynchronous resources that you can read
through and do some practical exercises
from basic analysis pipelines
to exploratory and downstream analysis
using r and python and all the way to
biological interpretation so this
program will really provide you with a
comprehensive set of resources and the
program sessions will link these
resources into a meaningful
flow of information and practice really
going from the very basics all the way
up until the expert level
now as you know
single cell transcriptomics has become
one of the
hottest most interesting areas of
research we're talking today about
multi-homic single cell sequencing we're
talking about signal cell proteomics and
even metabolomics so really single cell
has become
a very mainstream method that a lot of
labs are trying to apply to basic
research questions and even some to
translational research projects as well
so what you see on the slide is kind of
a
timeline
for when different single cell protocols
started to get published and we go from
all the way back in 2009 when the first
manual
protocol was designed for single cell
and all the way up until 2017
approximately 10x genomics has become
kind of one of the mainstream's methods
today
and today we have an ever-growing number
of protocols for different types of
applications and so what we will focus
in this program
is on
transcriptomics using single cell data
how is single cell transcriptomics data
different from bulk rna seq data
the main difference is that instead of
measuring the average temperature in a
hospital you're able to go to each
individual patient and understand who
has high fever and who has
who has died right and has no
temperature at all and so if you take
the average of those two somebody with
very high fever and somebody who's dead
you will end up with somebody who's not
even sick somebody who's maybe healthy
and so to understand the variability of
patients in the hospital you really want
to go to each individual and with single
cell rna-seq data it's the same thing
now because of that level of information
you also get a lot of noise and you also
get a lot of confusing signal and so
that's why
we will take a look at very specific
uh types of analysis
uh so we will look at uh methods like
monocle and silrat we'll look at pseudo
time analysis and clustering
differential gene expression we will
take a look at in-depth silverad methods
where we will explore how to
make a visualization
that is typically something that you
will expect to find in a publication for
example your umap plots we will take a
look at differential expression in the
context of different marker genes
we will take a look at pseudo time and
what are some of the considerations
around preparing the data for
pseudo-time analysis so all of these are
going to be very helpful skills if
you're going to try and deal with a
single cell data set
now as i mentioned all of this by itself
is pure theory and so it's important to
apply this kind of information to a
project is to give you practical
hands-on sense of how do you go from raw
data to biological interpretation and
that's why we have designed some
use cases around project examples
using cell line data
xenograft models
as well as clinical trials and some
translational applications so we will
take examples from high throughput
testing of drugs on cell lines we'll
take a look at tumor micro environment
and animal models and we'll also look at
tcga data the cancer genome atlas data
to try and appreciate real patient data
what does that actually look like
now in terms of the types of things that
we will get out from this is we will
look at the evolution of breast cancer
classification one of the most
significant progresses in diagnostics
and therapeutics has been made in the
area of breast cancer and one of the
reasons for that is because from just a
very
high level diagnosis based on marker
genes we are able to now go into the
deep molecular biology in each subtype
of breast cancer and understand how it
relates to treatment and to do that
we'll take a look at actual publication
so we'll take publications that have
made a significant significant impact on
this area and we'll make sure that we
can understand all of the specifics of
the methods that the authors have used
and these are publications that have
been
produced by both researchers as well as
people in the industry so these are
going to be papers from
companies like genentech novartis and
others that have really made the
progress with actual therapeutics and
diagnostic strategies for these diseases
now beyond that we will take a look at
patient-derived xenograft models at
modeling cancer precision medicine
you know immune changes in
macrophages tcga
and even we'll take a look at many other
types of projects so really a lot of
projects i'm not going to go into all of
them but especially i want to kind of
highlight how this could be relevant to
some of you that might be either doing
your masters or maybe phds
in different areas so we have here an
example of olga udartseva she's a
research affiliate a postdoctoral
research affiliate at roswell park
comprehensive cancer center and this is
what she has gotten out of program like
this she says the program is very well
structured and easy to learn the skills
that i gained through the program helped
me significantly enhance the relevance
of my project by making connections
between my pre-clinical study and its
practical applications to cancer
patients so really i hope that this
would be an outcome for all of you that
decide to join this training program
so to speak more about the